a rare sight went Magnus blown off a
completely winning
endgame how did this happen what exactly
did he miss let's find out in the nine
round of the 2023 World rapid
Championship Vincent chose the move
Bishop D6 in this position which is a
mistake however Magnus quickly put his
Knight on
D5 the problem is that now black can
play F5 and destroy the center and get
good counterplay on the king side which
actually happened in the game
later on the game fizzled out as a draw
however if Magnus had played Knight F5
then parently engine gives plus 2.6
Advantage let us understand why when
black saves his Bishop white has
probably the simplest plan in the world
which is to March the king in the center
Munch the C Pawn with a knight maneuver
and eventually get a clear past Pawn
Magnus realized it after some moments
and it shows that even endgame God is
human on some days